my task was this morning to consider the
role of scholars in library two point oh
and of course Blair asked me if I talk
about books since I have a relationship
with MIT press and some of em I tease
other publishing activities but I'm no
more obedient than anybody else on this
panel or anybody else that you'll hear
from today so what I thought I'd talk
about is something that's more
interesting to me than that because I
think books books are actually an
exceptionally mature and reliable way of
placing ideas in a stable format and
conducting an extended arguments in a
genre that people are well-acquainted
with and know how to use whether they're
formatted in terms of a hardcopy ink on
paper or whether they're formatted for
electronic delivery they are still books
and people recognize them the real
problem that publishers of books are
having these days is not that books
aren't a wonderful medium for what they
set out to do but it's rather that John
Paul frees students aren't reading
extended arguments anymore so the
question of the survival of
survivability of books has more to do
with whether we continue to train people
to value and read books as a way of
thinking than it has to do with whether
books themselves are inappropriate genre
for the extended argument so I thought
I'd talked this morning a little bit
about a discussion that was held among
the faculty at MIT that began in august
of 2008 that relates to the topic that
John raised in response to the last
question MIT faculty although you might
remember that it began as a technical
school MIT faculty actually represent
virtually every discipline that you'll
find in a contemporary University we
don't have a law school we don't have a
medical school but we have a lot of the
other same disciplines that any other
institution has
and after the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences at Harvard and the law school
at Harvard passed resolutions regarding
the contribution of the open-access of
the works of the faculty in those two
schools at Harvard the faculty chairman
at MIT got a lot of requests from
faculty to ask whether and mighty
faculty shouldn't consider doing
something along the same lines so in
September of 2008 faculty chairman
convened a interdisciplinary cross
school multi department 12-member ad hoc
faculty committee to consider the
question of how MIT faculty published
their work what they what they do with
the scholarly publications they use how
that work should be disseminated and to
pay particular attention to the
possibility of providing open access to
those publications the intent of the
charge to the committee which i
co-chaired with my Peter isn't he good
how many librarians does it take to make
a powerpoint cipher
so um the faculty the lowest you up here
we go ah they put it on that all right
they put on the macbook that's why it's
working so the the faculty began its
work in in September and a number of
interesting aspects of the way faculty
consider their role in scholarly the
dissemination of scholarly work and new
research became quite vividly available
as a result of the conversations that we
were having first in the committee and
then with the faculty as a whole it's
safe to say that the mental model that
virtually every faculty member has is
the one that's in front of you libraries
are traditional as far as they were
concerned they wrote books and journal
articles those things were purchased by
libraries they were held in unaltered
and persistent ways and everybody lived
happily ever after they were not the
least bit confused by the fact that on a
day-to-day basis they worked in an
entirely different way than that that
many of them said quite proudly that
they hadn't actually set foot in the
library for quite a long time thank you
very much and they were fully connected
no matter where they were by magic to to
a sophisticated network of information
resources that provided everything that
they need at all times but it was really
important that we still have all those
stacks in those books because that's
where their work was persistently
archived
another thing that we learned is that
each individual faculty member lived in
complete and total confidence that the
world of scholarly communication worked
exactly as their discipline worked so
the historians were quite sure that
biologists works in that exactly the
same way they did the physicists were
absolutely positive that mathematicians
were working as they did every
discipline believed that the process by
which new knowledge is created and
committed to some kind of a
communications medium and made
persistently available and affordable to
the people who needed to use it that
everybody did things exactly like they
did well of course we know perfectly
well that that's not the least bit true
and that each discipline has its own
traditions and practices and pursues
those with considerable vigor so as we
carried out the discussions first within
the committee and then across the
institution the committee ended up
visiting every department in every
school at MIT at one point to have a
conversation with the faculty about
their perceptions and five vivid themes
emerged from those conversations which
informed the resolution that MIT
ultimately passed faculty were
increasingly concerned about the fact
that copyright transfer agreements that
they were being asked to sign made it
difficult if not impossible for them to
use their own work this was deeply
concerning to people nevertheless they
did exactly what they wanted with their
own work and their their attitude was
the susumi model of distribution of work
but where this problem came home to them
was in their OpenCourseWare sites
because faculty at MIT quite proudly
contribute their courses to the
OpenCourseWare site and what they
discovered is they were contributing all
of their substantively rich
intellectual works to OpenCourseWare and
when they went and visited the site they
were gutted anything that had copyright
constraints on it had to get stripped
out from the open courseware site and so
they called OpenCourseWare to complain
no cursor said we couldn't get
permission and so the faculty called
their own publishers and they said what
are you doing what are you thinking it's
my stuff I want to put it up on
OpenCourseWare and the publisher said I
don't think so I own that go read the
agreement that you signed I own that and
you can't use it so it was quite
shocking I think to faculty to realize
the extent to which they had signed over
agreements that no longer let them
legally use their own work a second
theme that emerged from the discussions
was that it turns out that those who own
the copyright content copyrighted
content were increasingly asking the MIT
libraries to sign license agreements for
the use of that material that were
totally in conflict with the way the
Academy teaches and conducts research we
were being asked to sign license
agreements for one school and not
another in an interdisciplinary
environment faculty were astonished we
were being told that administrative
staff couldn't use materials that we
were bringing in for educational
purposes we were told that laboratories
that are affiliated with MIT couldn't
use resources because they were more
than two miles away totally arbitrary
distinction we were being asked to sign
license agreements that said that
visitors visiting scholars fittings
visiting students couldn't use the
resources that we realized something and
the faculty were just absolutely
astonished that they had found
themselves in a position where they gave
away their work for reasons of
communication and scholarship and
suddenly the license agreements were not
only expensive but they were they were
seeking to constrain who could use their
work a third theme that emerged that
shocked them equally badly was the
vulnerability of the electronic assets
the electronic library that you saw
library 2.0 is actually a library for
rent if you have enough money to live in
the penthouse you can rent access to
these resources but when you stop paying
you get evicted and students
increasingly are learning that as they
work in rich environments like Yale and
MIT and Harvard and elsewhere that when
they leave their institutions they lose
all access to the deep rich resources
that have been electronically available
to them and they fall off the edge of
the earth and then the last name of
course is that they had no idea how much
consolidation had gone on in the
publishing world the set of small
circles under 1998 show eight key
players which by 2008 had converged into
four key players and the faculty started
talking about this slide as the Death
Star's live because you can see one by
one the publishers are being the
commercial publishers are being sucked
into the big red blob in the middle and
you may have heard on Monday that
Springer has put its titles up for sale
so be interesting to see where they land
so as faculty looked at this kind of an
environment they were saying to
themselves oh my gosh this is really
unbelievable so I'm like this little dot
down on the bottom and I'm trying to
negotiate a license agreement to John's
point I'm trying to negotiate a license
agreement with a Death Star good luck to
me and the Red Sox is all I can say
and then finally the last thing that
emerged was that they can't do data
mining and for the first time I think
this came it came home to them why the
National Institutes of Health has asked
to ask their principal investigators to
make articles available to them one of
the purposes of which is to do data
mining and the faculty suddenly were
realizing that's the kinds of research
projects that they wanted to do that
involve data mining across corpuses of
information we're illegal and in fact if
you read the google book search
settlement agreement that's proposed you
will see that google also retains total
control over who gets to do data mining
in the corpus so as a research tool
these great bodies of information that
is that are digitally formatted have
tremendous possibility for research
projects but you can't do it without
their permission and indeed Google is
going to make sure nobody can do it
without theirs so out of these
discussions came a really important
consideration which is basically that
the system of journal publishing is
completely out of balance it pits one
individual author against an enormous
monolithic international multi multi
disciplinary publishing agreement and
the faculty don't stand a chance even if
they wanted to change things so the
faculty concluded that it would be much
better again to John's point to think
about a collective action and when they
pondered how best to do that they
decided that one thing they could do you
know mother Harvard but it was that they
could bring daddy and mighty to the
table because from their point of view
although elsevier is a nine billion
dollar enterprise mit is a two billion
dollar enterprise and that makes them a
little bit bigger than some other places
and if they thought well you know if
Harvard's going there there are pretty
big enterprise and MIT pretty soon you
have enough weight on your side of the
table
you can get serious attention so on
March 18th the faculty of MIT passed an
open access policy which benefited
greatly from the learnings that went on
at Harvard it's a little different
you'll see like the Harvard resolution
that's based on principle the commitment
to disseminate research and scholarship
as widely as possible it gives MIT
non-exclusive permission to make
available scholarly articles not books
just works that are written with no
expectation of compensation to further
the interests of a discipline or area of
scholarly research and it gives MIT the
right to exercise the copyright in those
articles for the purpose of open
dissemination provided the articles are
not sold for a profit the policy applies
to all scholarly articles written while
the person is a member of the faculty so
it starts on march 18th then goes
forward it's not retrospective and
provost of the pros designee which
happens to be me I get to waive
application automatically as long as I
get written notification and the author
tells me why they're opting out now the
reason we're collecting information
about why people opt out is not because
we don't want them to opt out but we
think over time we'll build a database
of the reasons why people are unable to
participate each faculty member makes an
electronic copy available it doesn't say
it depart that the faculty member
deposits just says it makes it available
so that enables us for instance to look
for those copies on a faculty members
website scrape them and dump them in D
space which is where we're running them
and it gives us the opportunity to make
these scholarly articles available in an
open access repository which we already
have and we have we actually have a few
items in the D space environment already
so the policy takes effect immediately
but there's a cycle back to the faculty
to review it policy issues are decided
by a standing committee of the
faculty and most importantly the faculty
committee that is responsible for this
is to make it as convenient for the
faculty as possible so we did learn from
Harvard that if you put an aggravation
layer in between the faculty and what
you're trying to accomplish it makes it
a lot harder to get there so in summary
I think what we learned from the
discussions that we had with with
faculty is MIT faculty at least are
pretty sophisticated about the book
contracts that they sign they don't
expect to get rich on them but they
understand that environment pretty well
they were shocked to find out that the
termites had gotten into the scholarly
literature scholarly journal literature
and that in fact although it looked
beautiful and solid on the outside it
had been completely hollowed out on the
inside by virtue of one drop at a time
one little termite at a time taking the
wood out of the middle of the post and
there's a shell around what a library
looks like on the journal side now
that's completely empty unless you throw
money at publishers so faculty want to
increase open access they think that we
have a process in place where they can
act as a body and not just as
individuals and they've decided to
pursue this path by giving MIT the
institution the authority that's
necessary to work on behalf of faculty
to preserve and share the record and
there's obviously a key role for
libraries in that and I thank you for
your attention
okay so Charles Greenberg will wrap it
up here yes I'm sorry yeah Charles
groaning
my two files
this one yep
and this is your file right
now what do I do to the other
yesterday on Charlie Rose the ada louise
huxtable was being interviewed and at
the end of the interview Charlie Rose
asked her what will the what will New
York City look like in the future and
she demurred and said I'm not a not a
futurist I'm an optimist and that's
pretty much the way I'm approaching the
question of a library to point oh and I
do find that the more specific our
predictions on these matters the less
oppression they'll they appear down the
line this is all by way of caution to in
terms of what I'm going to be talking
about which is a very generalized nature
some comments on the public or municipal
library i'm taking a I think much
deserve a break from academic libraries
in her essay hours in a library Virginia
Woolf identify two types of readers
quoting Virginia Woolf a learned man is
sedentary concentrated solitary
enthusiast who searches through books to
discover some particular grain of truth
upon which he has set his heart if the
passion for reading conquers him his
gains dwindle and vanished between his
fingers a reader on the other hand by
this I think she means more general a
generalized reader must check the desire
for learning at the outset if knowledge
sticks to him well and good but to go in
pursuit of it to read on a system to
become a specialist or an authority is
very apt to kill what it suits us to
consider the more humane passion for
pure and disinterested reading if we
extrapolate from wolf we can identify
two types of libraries that roughly
corresponds to her on one hand the
searching acquisitive reader and on the
other what I'm calling the more hedonic
Lee oriented reader whose delectation
derives as much from the artfulness of
the writing as from the factual
information it conveys and these are of
course the academic we
search University Library and secondly
what we commonly know as the municipal
or public library and of course there
are there are hybrids like the Chicago
New York and Los Angeles libraries those
with access to research libraries can
easily pivot between their roles as the
searching acquisitive readers getting
the most recent economics and medical
research or as hedonic readers obtaining
the most recent titles fiction titles
from the New York Times bestseller list
but those whose access is limited to
public libraries have less flexibility
in this regard and find it much more
difficult then do those with access to
academic libraries to morph from the
hedonic reader into a successful
acquisitive searching reader practically
all libraries have as a primary if not
the primary goal or even exclusive
mission to promote reading by the
distribution of works of authorship
whose primary purpose is to be read and
by reading I mean the cognitive process
of understanding a written linguistic
message particularly through verbal or
musical symbols and libraries have have
historically privileged symbolic works
literary and to a lesser extent musical
works and rightly so I believe because
these works allow for the transmission
and understanding of the most complex
information to the greatest number of
readers it's possible to read tea leaves
anybody know what the language of tea
leaves Tea Leaf reading is it's Tessa
Murphy TAS geography and to read flower
arrangements this one's much easier
what's the what's the word for the
language of flowers is Fleur iographer
um but for obvious reasons libraries
don't collect or circulate tea leaves or
flower arrangements
so let's talk a little bit about the
public library of the present but before
we get there let's talk about the public
library of the past in particular my
past this is a picture of the first
library I knew as a toddler when I
showed this this image to my wife she
said I didn't know who you grew up in
Alabama I didn't actually this is
believe it or not in Washington DC about
a half a mile from Georgetown and the
building still exists this photo was to
be fair taken in 1928 but in the in the
in the Johnson error when I when I knew
it it was a it was exactly it looked
exactly like this and still does it's
now called the discovery creek music
museum i believe and it's on macarthur
boulevard in Washington it was one room
with with a librarians desk and a bunch
of a bunch of books that's it it was a
place where you you visited to borrow
books to read elsewhere sort of a kind
of a homespun version of the of the
Carnegie aspirational libraries in which
which the populace at large was
encouraged to read them themselves
towards a better existence for the past
40 years there's been I think in what I
call it sort of an identity crisis for
the public library in principally in
reaction to technological and social
changes public libraries today's
struggle not only to adopt to adapt to
new technologies but also to the
relatively new presumption thank you up
to the relatively new presumption that
libraries will provide content for all
of them I'm from just south of Los
Angeles in a city called Newport Beach
which is a magnificent library and in
Newport Beach a public library of the
1.7 million circulation transact
last year 750,000 of them were for
feature films so over forty percent for
feature films very interesting when you
think about technology back about a
hundred years or so ago piano rolls were
enormously popular sort of the ipod of
the of the turn of the century the way
people obtained new new musical works
and her new musical works but by and
large public libraries did not
systematically collect or distribute
piano rolls because these were
considered essentially works of
entertainment the exodus by literate and
affluent families from large cities to
the suburbs between the 1960s and 90s
and the commensurate flagging of tax
revenues are contributed to the creeping
many would say galloping dezzy itude of
urban public libraries since then these
libraries have struggled to remain
viable attempting to attract visitors
and funds obviously by being all things
to all people through programs and
services far outside those of the
traditional public library but I believe
that this reallocation of human and
physical resources is compromised the
efficacy of the public library as a
place devoted to readers as a place of
human aspiration and let's go back to
the Newport Beach Public Library for
just a second I mentioned that it's an
absolutely magnificent building if it's
it's a fabulously funded fabulous tax
base has a wonderful large informed
polite helpful staff it's teeming with
people it's like Costco on a week up
weekend it's just people pouring in and
out there are hundreds of beautiful
blonde wood private desks indoor/outdoor
reading areas acres of computer
terminals in other words what's not to
like or as Chico Marx would say was a
problem for you was a problem for me is
that no one is using the library's
information resources that computer
terminals I do occasional snoops through
that through the through the the two
floors of the library just out of
curiosity and just
kind of a very a non-scientific field
research the computer terminals um i
would say nine out of ten were being
used all of which were perfectly
functional which is which is unusual for
a public library but computer terminals
were on being a 9 out of 10 were being
used either for email or for for online
shopping from what I could tell are
looking at real estate the reading areas
the adult serious reading was that
what's going on we're being used by
people to fill out their tax returns um
studying for real estate certification
exams high school homework was acting
they're all actually goofing off but
theoretically there for to do their high
school homework and then you of course
find one or two homeless or deranged
people furtively sleeping or washing up
in the bathrooms blending a free zone of
disquiet to the entire operation what
this this trying to be all things to all
people has done of course is diverted
funds from the the library's primary
mission of promoting reading if you look
at the Los Angeles Public Library for
instance which has budget of 124 million
dollars last year only 10 million of
that is is spent on acquisitions 7
million of that is spent for what is
roughly called cultural programs and
this involves exhibitions the library
store and library awareness programs
which I find very mysterious um you
can't get access to read to information
that I take for granted and use
constantly on through JSTOR no access to
JSTOR whatever no access to art store no
access to the new Grove dictionary of
music on online no access to to noxus
music and obviously no lexus or westlaw
New York Public Library a budget of over
300 million dollars only seven to eight
percent of its annual budget is spent on
acquisitions um jstor arc store Grove
dictionary yes they do have have access
to the electronic versions of them
but you have to go to the library in
order to use it completely defeating in
my right the the the the purpose of
these electronic versions and certainly
no noxious music and and certainly no
access to lexis or west log my
misgivings aside about the current state
of public libraries I am sanguine about
their future in large measure because i
believe the non rival wrists and
intangible attributes of digital
resources will ultimately promote
changes in the allocation of public
libraries human and material resources
that will allow them to become
indistinguishable from academic research
libraries both in terms of breadth and
depth of information resources available
to all readers and specifically I think
this would mean the gradual dismantling
literally and figuratively of the public
library as a physical location in the
future if public libraries which would
shed their earthly coils and the panoply
of social services and responsibilities
that if they've been saddled with or
they've saddled themselves with over the
past 40 years they could reallocate
their resources to create a library of
the future virtually indistinguishable
from there there are academic
counterparts and specifically this would
they should I believe a focus their
resources on the creation acquisition
distribution and preservation of works
in electronic form and literacy programs
should be in my in my view devoted to
computer literacy programs making
everybody comfortable with the with the
technology so that they can use it not
not merely in the library but but but at
home and promote the idea finally that
the development of an access to
intangible information resources are
equally if not more valuable than
traditional objects philanthropic and
Ella moisten airy work at libraries like
building additions and book funds in
other words to cultivate the spirit of
the Andrew Carnegie's in the end the
digital age I'll wrap up with that
I can see Charles and Josh could have an
interesting conversation about the
appropriate role of public library is
based on that but my eye the first
question and that goes to an in her
capacity as the director of the MIT
press and that is this very difficult we
know to get our young scholar II get a
monograph published with prestigious
press like MIT how much more or less
difficult might that be do you suppose
10 years from now monograph is not that
it's not a perfectly worthy and
appropriate genre for sharing a an
extended argument the question is who
buys them because university presses
like commercial presses are predicated
on an assumption that money comes in to
offset the costs of the staff who do the
acquisitions who designed the product to
work with authors most authors I know
who write books are pretty Frank about
the fact that they never would have
gotten it done if they had a good editor
so there's a and there's design books
are designed it's hard to remember that
you pick a typeface in the format
hey just is selected and the cover is
identified in indexes and so there's a
fair amount of labor that goes into
creating a scholarly monograph and then
you have to figure out how to get to
your markets and there are lots of
cheaper ways to do that today than
mailing postcards to people but in fact
there are costs associated with
producing a scholarly monograph and they
are editorial and they are interactive
so places like the MIT press are looking
at lots of options for managing down the
costs associated with producing a
scholarly monograph they use every
electronic tool they can find but you
still have to have some way of covering
the cost unless you want a place like
MIT to cover all the costs of production
which case then you have a serious free
rider problem because as universities
across the land shut down their
University presses or trivialize them by
reducing them to is going to fit
somebody regional publishing you find
that the avenues for scholarly
monographs are smaller and smaller and
the economics of supporting scholarly
monographic publishing are
less so I think unless we can
collectively figure out how to support
the cost of the enterprise we will find
ourselves in a position where those who
have works they want to share in lisanna
known as the book which supports an
extended argument that there will be no
way to produce those and even electronic
publishing but takes only a small
percentage of the cost out of the book
you could go to print on demand you
could do lots you could go to all ebooks
but you would still have the upfront
costs associated with producing a
high-quality peer-reviewed scholarly
monograph even if you produce it
electronically thank you and Charles got
me to thinking about something that's
been on my mind for for the last year or
so so a comment and then a question it
seems to me that a very high calling a
very good goal for a large partnership
would be that of making information
helping information to be widely
available for our citizens and an also
touched on this and I can imagine a
partnership in which the public
libraries who know and interact with
their clientele a whole lot in whatever
ways the academic libraries who know
about art store and JSTOR and have
expertise in licensing in contact with
publishers and governments and funding
agencies who can help make this happen
could somehow collaborate for much
broader access than we currently are
providing in today's society and that
seems to me like something very much
worth doing I was wondering if any of
the speakers know of such initiatives in
any community in any state in any
country of the world
well I would say there there are some
states until the current meltdown in tax
revenue that took it as their
responsibility I think here of Georgia
for instance which the state of Georgia
collaborated with public libraries and
university libraries to license for
every citizen in the state a set of
electronic assets that look pretty much
like what Charles was arguing for the
challenge is that the prices that
publishers charge for electronic
resources are staggeringly high and they
are monopolies for all intents and
purposes so to the extent that a large
publisher will indeed give a discount to
a state like Georgia to distribute
resources to public libraries university
libraries citizens in their home it was
a very interesting experiment and I my
understanding it was very heavily used
well I just I'm sorry to stand up again
I just just kind of beg to differ at the
slightly negative cast of that I think
that unless groups of us get together to
try to make that kind of case an
argument we will always have reasons to
not do it and one of the biggest reasons
will be that the publishers are big and
nasty and charged loved money oh i
misunderstood me he missed yesterday I
was not saying okay that there was a
reason not to do it I was saying right
that but that's one of the obstacles
that one maybe Israeli ozols and and we
are managing to do it in developing
countries I wish we could do it in
undeveloped countries you know what I
mean I think it's it's as I as I'm
suggesting it's it's
I think heavily a matter of reallocation
of resources why is it that universities
do have access to to some of these
superb electronic resources is because
because there's a demand for it and the
universe is decided to put their money a
direct money toward it um and haven't
decided to direct their money towards
more frivolous things like life's
collaborations john wants to get
something anything Josh so um and first
of all we should have listened to you
five years ago and we should listen to
you now I think this is totally
important and we'll have the discussion
later of the google book settlement
which we actually oddly enough haven't
really discussed in this panel but i
think it's rip the elephant in the room
in this respect and i think the question
of whether or not the google books
element precludes in any way either de
jour de facto some of the collaborations
you're talking about at least for some
you know set of knowledge is really an
important question and one of the ones
that is most important to us but I would
also note for that Anna's director of
the MIT press is a major part of this
solution the kinds of agreements I'm an
MIT press author that you have enabled
us to do both as a journal article
author and as a monograph author are
great and if every publisher were to
follow and lead think would be a lot
easier if I can just just add for a
second at least from the from the New
York Public Library perspective because
in one sense we are that kind of
arrangement in that it's we're a public
library the library that serves three of
the five boroughs of New York City an
entire socio-economic spectrum and at
the same time has really deep knowledge
of the research needs of the research
collections it's not a matter of like
institutional will or scraping up the
money to do it or making that a priority
it's that the business model of
institutional subscriptions is tailored
to a very specific market which is the
University in higher education context
and a handful of corporations that have
particular particular needs which means
that the model of paying per FTE or
or kind of in that in that vein
fundamentally breaks when you look at
the broad public access mandate of of a
public library so so for example at nypl
you can get jstor in the building you
can't get it outside the building
because when we when we go and try to
try to figure out okay what would it
cost and you calculate on an FTE basis
the entire population or even just
Manhattan and you notice that and you
think okay if nypl offers that then you
know we've actually had cases where
we've licensed subscriptions on a sort
of borough-wide case and nyu and
columbia and the dozens of other
universities start dropping their
subscription so it's that there needs to
be a paradigm shift to to a sort of
statewide or much like the unit of
analysis of the institution is too small
if you want to effect that broader
change okay so we have we have to move
on there's three questions that we can
have asked this question to ask one
right after another and then the panel
will answer them so in the interest of
time run out so I'm very glad to hear
that these major libraries are
committing to not just be collective
bargaining agents to go and buy from a
few corporations but actually produce
information services and the steps that
Harvard and MIT have made to go and push
back on the journal publishers to create
open access I just say thank goodness
and if I could ask Anne and John just
what were some of the politics and
issues around it and specifically from
the perspective of can we cause a
movement here can other organizations
that are you know maybe not you know can
we get the rest of the university's
copying your template or what are they
going to run into next question I would
first like to suggest that looking at
the state of Delaware and the University
of Delaware's partnership with the state
libraries in the public libraries and
the public schools is exactly what Ann
was asking about and you deal I've
searched the University of Delaware does
negotiate the licenses on behalf of the
state I believe or at least
how it was a couple of years ago when I
worked there and it increased the buying
power and provided access to you had a
public library card in the state you
could access those databases that's one
solution and I'd also i'm just curious
john i think was the only person who
mentioned special collections and i'm
curious where where rare books and
archives fall in in the rest of the
panels dots thank you okay great last
much so i have a pro consolidation
question is there enough consolidate the
MIT issue of consolidation of off of
faculty members really made let me think
of this should there be a cathedral
called law library calm which is the big
library in the sky and leaves the bazaar
for each individual library and is it
accreditation standards that limit the
capacity of law school to rationalize in
terms of the organization and provision
of services on the on a databases basis
okay great good three questions so this
first one is what were the obstacles to
open access this is john and ann
well maybe I can answer this because
John knowledge is probably MIT addressed
this issue across all the faculty which
made it an interesting question not that
it's not interesting in law schools and
the Faculty of Arts and Sciences the
obstacles were actually quite finite one
was if you had a policy of this kind and
a publisher refused to publish an
article of a junior faculty member would
you be penalizing the junior faculty
members career if they couldn't publish
in that journal and we know that there
are a number of journals who are
adamantly committed to maintaining total
control over the intellectual property
that they publish so that was one of the
serious reasons for the waiver you don't
even have to have you don't have to ask
for the waiver you get it automatically
but we do want people to ask us for it
in writing and we do want them to tell
us why they're asking for it because
it's important to know if a particular
article or publisher or group of
publishers have a policy that says that
they will not accept any article where
there is a non exclusive right granted
to the University so I would say that
was one issue and the other obstacle was
that there are about a thousand faculty
members at MIT which means there are
about 1,200 opinions
about what the right thing to do they're
not all economists that's why it's such
a low number about about what it is
you're supposed to do with your work and
how you can manage it and who owns it
and what kind of trust and confidence
you have in your in your host
institution at any point in time and
concern for small publishers in in
academic disciplines where scholarly
societies and associations manage most
of the publishing so again the opt-out
was envisioned as a way a faculty member
could not put a small publisher small
Society publisher in in an awkward
position if indeed it was problematic
for them to publish in that place for
whatever reason so Brewster the end has
hit Muslim we did an faq of the
responses and I'm happy to share that to
see you know what were the what were the
arguments against it the only one I
would add which I think may apply to
everyone now and even more so than on
Harvard and MIT instances is cost it
does cost money on the part of the
university to implement it in terms of
staff and commitment and so forth and
that's you know legitimate critique that
Harvard MIT can afford to do it
analogous piece to that is some of the
publishers then say fine you want to do
it open access give us three grand or
whatever their cost is the fee right and
I think then a question for the
university is should you be paying that
fee should you have a common pool of
money to do it and I think that gets
into a really interesting question but I
admit that my fear we made this
commitment as a law school last night I
don't think any other law school has
made a similar equipment of this breath
on terms of faculties delighted to be
corrected if I'm wrong I'm worried that
no one will follow us right and it may
be the drivers in a position where we
can do it for whatever reason but I'm
anxious that your problem get solved i'm
delighted that MIT did it across all the
faculties i cannot imagine how an and
others manage those politics but it's
thrilling to the point about law schools
working together I think that's mostly
been hubris that has kept us from
collaborating in this particular way
honestly and I think it's probably those
of us like Harvard who compete or have
competed in the size of
collection we need to call that over
that's a dumb competition we should
compete on how good we are as
collaborators to creating this new
vision and you know sign up with lair
and others we need to do that and
there's I think there's a lot more
collaboration than people outside of the
library world realized that we do work
together to share a collection and so
we've had ongoing for the past 20 years
in Northeast agreements on how to share
foreign and international law
collections who has responsibility for
collecting for particular countries and
so on and we work with nelco I think
Tracy Thompson might be in the audience
she's our executive director of Melko
and she's done a lot of work to the Oval
school graduate don't a lot of work
towards getting law libraries to work
together on a whole whole lot of fronts
but there's more that can be done there
I'm Special Collections I yes yes I
think go to all of us would they have
special collections we we see this as a
big part of the future of print that
we're putting money into that area that
we're growing our special collections
that we're focusing on them for I
digitization projects we're very proud
with special collections here we've
taken over special collections from
other law libraries so we've acquired a
huge part to the rear book collection
from the from libraries care less about
those collections so so thank you very
much we have to bring other session to a
close